you're about to learn how to code an
e-commerce website using
django and vue that means you'll be
using python on the backend and
javascript on the front end
you just need to know a basic
understanding of these technologies to
follow along
this course was created by code with
stein he's created a bunch of great
courses on his own channel
and we wanted to bring him to a larger
audience
hi in this video we're going to build
the e-commerce website using django
and vue i'm going to use django rest
framework to build the api
and the back end and then i'm going to
use vue.js to build a separate front end
which we're going to use to connect
to the backend using axios to handle the
payments i'm going to use something
called stripe
this course will assume that you have
basic knowledge of both view and django
but i will still try to explain
everything as good as i can so hopefully
you should be able to follow along
anyway let me show a little demo of what
we are building so it's easier for you
to understand
and follow along here you can see the
project we are going to build
we have a simple menu with the search
the categories
login button and the cart button and
have a simple header which is
uh welcomes you to the page this is a
jacket store
you have the latest products and a
simple footer
i go into one of the categories you'll
see the products from this category
and if i click view details you will see
the full version of it
with a bigger image title and a
description
you also have the price here and the
possibility to add to cart
and if i click add to cart you'll see a
little pop-up down here which says that
the product was added to the cart
if i now go to the cart we have the
possibility to
change the quantity and you can also
remove them from here if you want to
like that and then the price updates
here and also down here
and if i now try to proceed to checkout
just log in with my username
code with stein put my password
and then i headed to the checkout page
here i need to fill out
contact information card number etc
and then we click paid stripe and when
send back to the page afterwards
to a simple success page and if i go to
my account
here i would have a list of my orders if
i had any i don't have any in this
version
of this jacket store right now and i
also have possibility to log out
so that's basically the product we are
going to build i hope it looks really
interesting to follow along with i'm
going to build everything from scratch
and step by step and when we finish
we're going to deploy this project to a
live server on digitalocean
but now it's time to get started with
the coding
here i have the to-do list you are going
to go through in this video
it's quite long but we're just going to
start at the top and work
our way down first i'm going to install
a setup django and everything we need
there
i have a folder here jackets would be
which will be the root folder for all of
this project
view django and everything we need okay
inside this folder i want to create
something called an environment
it's a virtual environment and every
python package we install here will only
be for this environment
so when we are deploying this project
later it will it will be much easier to
have the same
environment locally and in production
and to create this just a virtual
env and an environment
eight or three eight two which is the
python version i'm running
and hit enter so now i have now i have
it there on the computer
we just click ls you'll see here the
environment folder
and then i need to activate it so we can
install some packages
and to do this i said source environment
then activate as you can see here we
have prepared the no environment
382 this means that if i now use pip to
install something
it will only be installed inside this
environment
and if you don't have virtual
environment you can install it by just
writing pip install virtual env in one
word
like this pip install virtual
env i already have it installed but you
obviously need to install it
if you don't have it it might be a
little bit overwhelming with all
this environment and everything you're
going to install right now but
we'll come back to much of this later in
this video so then it
hopefully will make much more sense when
we go through
them multiple times so the first thing
we're going to install now is django
so just pip install django
this will install the latest stable
version of django and also a few
dependencies that django has
latest version of django is currently
three one seven
next we are going to install the django
rest framework
to this you just say pip install django
rest framework this is what you're using
to create the api
in the back end and hit enter this
also has a few dependencies and then we
can install
django dash course dash headers this
will help us with security so everything
between api and backend will be working
securely
and then we are going to install joser
this will also help us with
authentication
users and similar juicer adds some a few
endpoints to the api so it's easy to
create users
log in get a token for authentication
and similar
so just hit enter and this also
installs a few dependencies and then
we can install pillow this will help us
with
resize images and similar this is a
python image library
but pillow is a different version of it
but it's much
better and really easy to use and the
last thing you're going to install in
the back end is a stripe
so just right click install strip
so now everything in the back end is
installed and we can start configuring
it we just need to
create a new django project and to
create the new django project you say
django
admin start project and then the name i
just want to call it jacket
underscore django so i know it's the
django part of this project
and if i go into it check it's
underscore django
have a new folder in there and a file
managed pi is used to run administrative
tasks like initialize the database
create super users and similar
and inside the jackets django i can open
it here
so it's easier to see i have a initial
spine that just means that python should
handle this as a package asgi
and wsgi are entry points for the web
server
settings to spy are globally
configuration for the whole
project and urls.pi is kind of like a
table of contents of all the pages in
the backend
so i will come back to all of these
later so we don't have to think
too much about it yet okay and then we
need to tell
django about those packages we installed
so if you're going to set install pi
oops we have a list of installed apps
there are a few that comes from django
these ones
but we want to add more to this first we
had
the rest framework just so now django
knows that we are going to use it as
well
and then the next is restframework.org
token because we're going to use
what tokens for the authentication
and course headers we installed and also
joser so now we have
uh said to django that we're going to
use all of those
and then the next thing we're going to
use do the next thing we're going to do
is to configure the
course headers so below here add two
lines
course allowed origins this will be the
address to the front and
later you need to change this to the
live server address
or if you use a different address for
the front end than i am
and we also need to change the
middleware middleware is the
coded and that goes in the back end of
django so above it's important it is
above
common middleware you say
courseheaders.middlewear.course
middleware
so it's just that the django u goes
through this code before it goes to the
next part of the django code
and that's it for the configuration so
now we have done everything for the
security in the backend for now
then the last thing we're going to do is
to go to urls
just to remove this big comment here
and i'm going to include the api fonts i
told you about for joe sir so we are
ready to create users
but you need to import one more thing
from django.urls and this
includes so you can include pots from
that project
so first pod api slash v1
we include jose.urls
and the same bot here and
includejoser.urls.token
so now we have everything we need in the
back end this has added a lot of cool
functionalities and now we can create
users you can get authentication tokens
and similar from the front and it looks
a little bit like
magic because now we get a lot of
functionality without doing a lot
but you will probably understand a lot
more when you have used it a little bit
so you can just save this file for now
and then
i want to do one more thing here in the
backend and that
is to initialize the database and to do
that i said python
managed to apply make migrations
that's just to create the migrations
files
and then to run them i say python
mentioned by
migrate so now we have a new database
with all of these tables
so to test that everything is working we
can also create a super user we can log
into the admin interface
that django comes built within python
management by create super user
oops super
user and then i want the username to be
admin
admin jackets.com
and then a password
hit enter and now the superuser created
successfully
perfect and then to log into the admin
interface we can run the development
server that django comes with by saying
python
mentioned by run server
this will store the development server
at this address
just copy this address go to chrome
and it's not found because these are the
only urls that are available
but if i go to slash admin i can log in
with the admin account i just
created
and everything here seems to be working
we have the auth tokens but there are
none yet of course
and if i go to users i will see the user
i created
a new search is signed in and using the
front end will appear here as well
so that should be it for the back and
for now
now i can set the first task here to
done
next step now is to install a setup view
and i just want to open up a new
terminal just for view
so cd documents and jackets
that should be the correct folder okay
and to create a new
view project you need to install view
cli first to install it
just say npm install g at
view cli this will install the newest
version of view
on your computer and when and just hit
enter but i already installed it i'm not
going to go through it right now
so since i'm right here now i can create
a new project by saying
view create and then check it
oops check view should be the name of
the project
and i want to manually select which
features we're going to use
we won't be able to transcribe the code
real javascript i'm going to use the
router
the view x css preprocessors
i can just remove the linter
and then i can hit enter
going to select 3.x preview
and i'm going to use history mode for
the router
yes and i want to use dart says
and i can store this in dedicated config
files
and i don't need to save this for later
no so now this will install
now create a new gnoview project
and install the dependencies that view
has
great so now i can go into it cd jackets
view
oops check it view and i need two
packages or libraries
here as well to install them i can just
say npm
install axios this is a library you're
going to use to talk to the back end
and npm install bulma
this is a css framework i'm going to use
i don't have to think too much about the
styling and similar for this project
because we're here to
learn vue and django so now everything
there is installed
i go back to visual studio code just
look at the files here
we have something called node modules
which is the the
packages we have installed public
is the index.html which is the
file we're going to serve and we have a
few other
config files and in the source we have
the main.js which
creates the view app app.view is kind of
like the wrapper around all of the
code views are the different pages
store is view x which is a global state
management
for the whole app router is almost like
the urls
does pi in the django project it's all
of the pages in the project
components are small or large reusable
parts of
code we're going to use as well and
assets will be
images and similar i know it's a little
bit
much information right now but when we
just only
start adding code to each of them you'll
probably understand what each of them do
when you just done it a couple of times
and if you want to use
bootstrap instead of bulma you are free
to do so but i'm not going to do that
and it will be a little bit different
but it's up to you what you want to do
and if you want to test the view
everything is okay we can say
npm run serve so this will start a
development server
and this is the address we added in the
backend just
in the settings to spy so if i now go
open up a new tab hit enter you'll see
everything
you'll see the front page of the view
here and switch route
so we see that everything is working
perfect
so now i can go back to the to-do list
and set this task to done
next step now is to include font also i
want to use some icons around
different places in the page so it's
very easy to implement
i just go into public and into the
index.html and then below the title here
i just paste this one linked real
stylesheet
and then the link to the cdn which holds
version 550 and two of of uh
font awesome and save
so this shouldn't have done anything
with the front end so
you can just go back here again as that
this task clip done
next now is i want to do some changes to
the base template i want the
menu and i want to remove all of this
which doesn't have anything with our
ecommerce website to do
so if i just go back to app.view
make this a little bit smaller and i can
remove the contents here
and i want to import my hair and to do
that i just say at
import dot slash
node modules
slash bulma i think that's everything i
need
for refresh now yes it looks like i have
gotten the styling
and i can remove this nav bar i want to
create a div
id wrapper around all of the content
just to have one element in this
template because that's required by view
then i want to create a nav with class
navbar is dark this is bulma clauses
which will give a menu on the top with
the dark theme
close the nav just go in here said div
class nav bar brand this will be the
logo
and then to show the jackets logo there
i create a router link
to just slash which is the front page
and give it a class of
nav bar item and then i just a strong
jacket and close the strong and also
close the router link
down here i want to create the
possibility to have a
hamburger menu icon when you are on
small devices so we just say a
close nav war burger area label
expanded false data target nav bar menu
network menu will be the menu that shows
when we click this icon
and then add three of these which are
three stripes in the burger
then i can close the nav bar brand
and then add a new div class navbar menu
which you can see
this are linked like that and one more
div class
nav bar and because i want the menu to
be on one side
of the page and the logo on the other
page now the other side of the menu
and here i want to add the two
categories we're going to have summer
and winter it's just
router link to slash winter class navbar
item and then the label we're going to
show in the menu
and then the button for the card is a
little bit more complicated
first we need to add a div close nav bar
item
and then a div close buttons because
we're going to have two buttons
and to get space between them we add
this buttons clause
and then the login button is just router
link to slash
log in button a slide to have a light
grey button with the label
log in and the same with the chord it's
just slash chord
and it's success it's green is a little
bit more pretty or
inviting to click on and here i want to
show a
shopping cart icon spam clause icon
and i close fos fa shopping cards
and then spam spam card
and close the spam and close the router
link
close the buttons and close the nav bar
item
and then to get a little bit space
below the menu and around the content
we add around this router view a section
clause
section the router view is where all of
the content is placed
and then below there we have a footer
class footer
and then just simple paragraph showing
copyright
2021 and class has text centered
footer and save so if i now go here
you'll see that we have this menu and
everything from this logo
and down here is inside that router view
so if i now
go to slash about which is a page that
exists
this is the router view content
great so i can also just go to
views and into home.view and clean it up
a little bit
and remove this one just say home
remove the import of the hello world
because we're not going to use it
right now save if i go back now i just
say home there
perfect so now i think
i can go back here and set this task to
done
because now the front end is finished
for now
and i can go back to the back end and
start working with the products we're
going to use
in this project okay and if for now we
just try to
test this on a mobile device you'll see
that we have this hamburger but nothing
happens once we click it
so we're going to need to implement some
view js to fix this
so if i just scroll down here create a
new
script and create a data
return this is that object and i want
one property here
show mobile set the default to false
because we don't want to show the mobile
when we open the page before we click
the button and to make it possible to
click it
we can go up here and find the button
and i add here at click so when we click
this
we call the function or the code in here
and just say
show mobile menu equals not show mobile
menu
so if it's true it will be false and if
it's false it will be true
so now we just need to append a clause
to this
one it's true and to do that i just go
at the end here
paste a little bit of code v bind so we
bind the attribute class
to show is active if the show mobile
menu is true
so if you just save this now this is a
view directive
if you wanted to know what this is
called
just refresh and if i click here now you
will see the menu
go up and down perfect
and then i can go back to the to-do list
and set this task to done
next step now is to go to the backend i
created django
app we're going to create database
models to
have information about the products and
the categories
and to create the django app we just
stop the server down here
and say python managed pi start app
and then the name which would be project
and hit
enter so now if i scroll
up there should be a new folder there
called product with the migrations
folder the init.pi
admin which will we use to register the
models we create with the admin
interface and apps
which is information or config about
just this app models.pi
is where we describe to the database
what types of information we're going to
use and store
tests or python tests and view those
buyers where we get information from the
database
and present it to the front end
so first we can go into models.pi and
just remove this
command okay so first i want to begin
with the category model
to create a new model with just a class
category
and pause in models.model i want
one field called name which is a chore
field with a max length of 255
this will be the name of the category
and then i want the slug which is the
address
version of the name models.slug
field
and i want to order the categories by
name
in the backend at least and to do that
you need to add something called class
meta which is options for the model
ordering create a tuple
name and this is a template you need to
add a comma there so it's iterable for
the backend
and i also want the string
representation of this object
because if we now add the category and
see it in the back end we'll only see
object blah blah blah
so we want to show the name instead to
do that we said def
underscore underscore str underscore
underscore
was it himself say return self.name
so that's much easier to understand what
type of object it is
and i need to create one more function
so we can get the url
for the category so it's easier to use
in front and later
this can this function is called get
absolute url
and to use it we just say return f so we
format it
with slash and inside there it pass in
the slug which is the address of the
category
and save next step now is to use the
migration script again to update the
database
but to do that we need to tell django
that this app exists
and to do that we need to go into
install apps and at the top here
i can say product so you need to you go
information inform
django about the app and not the model
so if i now go down here i said python
managed to apply
make migrations you'll see that you want
to create a new model called
category and then we need to run python
managed by migrate to actually create it
in the database now the product
cat no the product model will be a
little bit more complicated
first i need to import bytes io from io
because we're going to handle
images here and resizing and then i want
to import
peel which is pillow installed or
import image from that library and
from django.cod.files i want to import
files so it's easier to create
thumbnails and similar
now we can go down here and start
working on the model
clause product models dot model
the first field i want here is a
reference to the category
i want to use something called a foreign
key which is index in the database
or a relation key so first you just
pause in category
and set the related name so when on a
category
it's easier to get all the products by
just saying category.product.all
and if you delete one of the
categories we also delete all of the
products connected to it
then i can just copy the name because i
want to use that
and also the slug
then i want one field for the
description
this is set to blank equals true and
null equals true so it can be empty if
you don't want
descriptions for a certain product
then add a field for the price which is
a decimal field
set max digit to six and decimal places
to two
this might be different in your country
than here in norway
and then i want one field called image
which is image field
we upload this to a folder called
uploads i'll show you where we're going
to place this
soon set also these two blank and no
liquids true so we don't have to have
image on all of the products
and then one field called thumbnail
we're going to generate the terminal
based on image very soon i'll show you
how we do that
and the last field is the date time
field
with autumn now add set to true so when
we create a new product in the backend
it would automatically fill the date
time field so we know when it was added
to the database
then i can copy these two
i can actually copy all three of these
paste them down here but we don't want
to order this by name we want to order
by the newest
so copy minus date edit so we get them
in descending order
the string can also be self.name
but here i also need to append self
oops at the curly braces
self.category.slug
so now we get this log based on this
category field
and here we also need a few more get no
functions we need one for f get
image self here we
check if we have the image in that field
and if you do we return
the whole address so it's easier to use
in the front end
and then we just say self.image.url
if not we can just return an empty
string
and then we want the similar for the
thumbnail get
thumbnail if self dot thumbnail
now we can just return the url to the
thumbnail
else and we first need to check if we
have the image
because then we need to generate the
thumbnail
and if you have it we can say
self.thumbnail which refers to
this field then we call a function
called make thumbnail and pass in
the image we have for this and when
that's done we say
self.save so it's saved in the backend
or in the database
and then we can return the address here
but if the product doesn't have an image
we just need to return empty string
and now the last thing for this model is
to create the make
thumbnail so def
make thumbnail self and image
and we also need to set the default size
to 300
times 200 pixels wide and then we're
going to use the image we imported
at the top here to create a new object
based on this image just convert it to
rgb so we are
certain that everything is okay with the
picture and we just say
m.thumbnail and pause in the size we get
up here
so thumbnail is a in a built-in function
in
image there is a thumb
i o and use the byte style we imported
at the top
and we save the image within this
information
as a jpeg and quality is just at 85
because this is just a very small
thumbnail and then we need to
create a thumbnail using the file we
imported from
django core files and we pass in
image.name
and now we just return thumb nail
and save so now we will
set the thumbnail to the image or the
terminal generated and save it
and return so now we can update the
database again
run the make migration script
create product model and
migrate great so now everything there is
working
perfect so now i can run the server
again
so i have it running in the background
and i can go back here and set this task
to done
and sorry i just forgot one thing i need
to fix the
uploads folder so if i go to settings.pi
we just need to
tell django where to put the files
first is that media url to this this
will be appended to the end of the
address of the server
and the media root is where located on
the server we're going to upload the
images
so just paste there slash media
so now we can save we don't have any
errors and everything looks okay
perfect and then to use
the the media in the front end we just
need to go to urls and do a little
change here as well
so first we need to import the
possibility to use the settings
here in the urls file and we need to
use a function called static from urls
and at the end of the url patterns we
add static
use the media url and just tell django
where the document
root is this won't be used when they're
going to use live because they will use
a different server
so we are still going to see some
progress in the front end so it will be
a little bit more exciting
but we can now continue to the next task
which is create a serializers
and views for the project over products
the serializer is
where we get the information from the
database and turn it into json so we can
use it
in the front end and to create the
serializer we just scroll up
and find the product app create a new
file
serializers.pi
first we import serializers from the
django rest
framework now we can import the category
and project model since we are inside
inside the same folder as mods.pi we can
just say those
models and python will fix this for us
then we create the product serializer
and posin serializer dot model
serializer
to configure this we use the class meta
just like the models and we say model
equals product because we want to use
the product model to
get information and then i just
configure what fields we're going to use
in the front-end
fields this is
tuple and then we want the id
the name to get absolute url function
so we get it directly here the
description
the price get image and get thumbnail
so if you have an image and when we call
this for the first time the in terminals
will be generated for
us so this can be saved
next we need to create a view set so we
can actually
tell django what we are going to put in
or get from that model so from
dot serializers import product
serializer and i also need to import a
few things from the rest framework
i'm going to import api view and
import response from rest framework dot
response
and i need to import a product from
models
and then i want to create a view set for
getting the latest products
which are going to show on the front
page
so create a new clause called late test
products list
and pausing api view this is generic
views
built inside the django rest framework
helping us
do all of this magic then i want to
create a new function called get so we
can override that functionality
and do a little bit changes and we get
the product from the database by saying
products equals product
product.objects.all
and then we just want the first four or
the latest products
and then to convert this using the
product serializer
is a serializer equal product serializer
plus in the products and say man equals
three because we have more than one
object
and then we just return response and
position serializer.data
and we want a separate urls file inside
here to clip
keep things still tidy as possible
from django.urls import port
and include and from
dot views import latest product list
url patterns
so this is just the same as the other
file it's just more
clean to have it a separate file for
each of the models know each of the
each of the django apps actually i can
say from
product import views so it's a little
bit easier to separate them
later and then put
late latest products views dot latest
products list
as view and save
and then we just need to import this to
the other url spy file
so at the bottom here we say part api
slash b1
include product
dot urls
and save so everything still seems to be
okay here
i just go to the browser api
b1 and i don't get anything there but if
i go to
latest products
it's empty because they don't have any
products in the back end yet
so if you want to create a few products
we need to go back to
visual studio code and inside the
admin.pi file in the products app
you need to say from dot models import
category and product
and admin.site register category
and admin dot site register
product so if you now go back to the
admin interface
front page here you'll see that these
two appeared here
perfect so we can now add summer
summer with lower cases and winter
winter so now we have this hair
great and we can create a few products
summer brown leather
brown leather
the desk 199.
and just select image
just go in here select that one
open save so now we have one product
there
you can create one in the winter as well
warm jacket warm check it
the desk for this product
2.99
and select the winter image and save
and if i now go to the latest hair
refresh
you'll see that we get information about
this product
so we get the name the url the
description
price and the link to the images if i
open this in a new tab
you'll see that we can see the full size
and also
the thumbnail great
so now i can go to the tool list again
as a test task to done so now we can
finally do some work on the front and
again we're going to show the latest
products on the front page
so if i just go to home.view
first i just paste the code to show the
header with the welcome to check that
information
and then below here i want to list the
products
the first i created deep class column is
multiline
so i can have the title and also the
products next to each other below there
so then i paste a little bit more code
the plus column is 12
it fills out the screen h2 which
is size 2 which is medium sized and is
centered so the latest product stays on
the center of the screen
then i create a product and
for each of these columns i want to look
through the list of products we are
going to get very soon
to do that we say v4 product
in latest products oops products
and you see now here i've got an error
this is because
django no view expects that each of
these
elements are unique so you need to find
an attribute
to the product id the
point key product dot id
so for every iteration we bind the
data key to the id which should be
unique for each
product just close that one
div class box so we get a little bit
shadow around
product and at the top i want the image
figure class image and before so we get
a little bit space
below the image down to the text
and to insert the image we just say mv
bind src product dot get thumbnail
and this is the whole url to the image
we could use a shortcut to bind it by
just saying colon src
if we wanted to we can close the figure
then we want to show a little title h3
clause is size 4
and then we show the name by using the
curly brackets just like in django
as a product dot name below the name i
want to show the
price this is just a little b with each
size 6
has text gray and then the dollar sign
product.price
and then the last thing i want to add a
button to review details
but since we don't have that yet we can
just write view details
close that one if i save now and go back
first of all i get an error because i
forgot to close one of the divs
but it won't work because we haven't
created a function to get
the information from the backend so this
time we need to
use excels so first and down in the
script i say import
xios from excels
and then below there is a data
because you need a new object return
and latest product and create an empty
list
column there it's low here i want to go
into one of the
life cycles hooks of view called mounted
so when the this page is finished we
call this code
and that is this dot get latest
products and then
we create that method below here in a
new object methods
like that and in here we call excels
xcos dot
get api slash
v1 slash latest
products
and when that's done we get a response
back
from the server and then we can just
this dot latest product equals
response dot data because there's a list
of
objects so it's very easy to use like
this
and if you get any errors we can just
show them in the console for now
you can fix this later in the video and
a little thing
too i want to do is to create a simple
style object at the bottom
because on the image i want to remove
the spacing around it so it looks a
little bit more pretty
it's just margin top minus 125
same with the left and the right so if
we go back now
it still won't work because we try to
just go to
slash api so here we could write
the whole address to the server but i
want this to work
by default to do that
i need to go into main.js
as you can see here we haven't imported
excels
anyway so we need to import it here and
tell you to use it
so import excels
from xcos and then
below here i say excels.defaults
base url and then the address to the
server which you have running down here
and then after router i say excels
and save so everything should be working
and if i just go back here now we have
already gotten the latest products
from the server perfect
so now i can go to the to-do list one
more time
and said done next now we're going to
make it possible to click view details
and go
in to the detail page of a product
okay and the first thing you need to do
done is to create a new view set
for the detail of the of the product
so go back to views.pi and then
we create a new clause product detail
and also going to use the api view here
but instead of the get function we're
going to use a function called
get object and here we're going to pass
in the categories log
and also the product slug here we need
to
check if the object exists pressing try
and then we say return
product.object.filter
so we filter every product that is
inside
a category and then we get
the slug or the product based on the
products like we get up here
and if it doesn't exist we will get an
exception
so accept product
that does not exist this is the correct
exception for this
and then we want to erase the http 404
error and to use the 404 error we need
to
import it you can remove this render and
just
from django.http import http
404. so this is now a function
and then we want to override the get
parameter
or function like we did here so def get
get the request pass in the slugs and
format set to none
and then we get the product the same
product equal self.get object which
calls this function
and pass in the slugs
so we don't have to reuse this every
time
and we still want to use the product
serializer so we get all of these fields
for
the full version as well then we can
just say return response
and pass in the serializer just like up
here
and save next we need to go into the
urls file
and below here we create one more path
products slug it is a field or string
and here django nara requires that you
pass in a slug which we call
category slug and once local products
log
these are references to these two
and then we just say we're going to use
views dot product detail i'm going to
render it as a view
and save so now we have a view
for showing the product next is to
create
a view page it's not a view like in
django view but viewers in view
so if you just go down here and into
views
create a new file called product
dot view in here we always begin with
empty template and empty script
name can be set to product and we can
say data return
can just be empty for now and we can
import excels
from excels because you know we want to
use this
first i like to create one div class
element page product
just don't know which page we are on and
then
create a div class column it's
multi-line
and then to the left on the screen we
have a div class s9 which is almost a
whole
width to show the image the title and
the description
first we showed image just like in the
list
of protests but here we use mb6 we get
even more space below
and we bind src attributes to project
get image instead of get thumbnail
and below here i want to show the title
so h1 clause title type and add this
clause we get it
very big and pass in project.name
and below there i want to show the
description now you can close this
column
create one more div close
column oops s3
close that div first you just want to
show a subtitle with information
about the product then i want to show
the price
and i prefix it with a dollar sign
and then i add the button and input
field for the add to cart functionality
this is a has add-ons which means that
the button and input value will be
into each other i use input type number
because i
expect to get the number in the back end
and class input so it gets pretty
styling and the minimum
i allow is one and then i bind the model
this field to a data object called
quantity
so if i now go down here inside data
i can say quantity
one sorry not these quotes like that
so this is default now to one and it
can't go below
one and then below there i create a new
clause control
and have simple button add to cart i
will fix this later in this video
and then to get the product from the
server we need to use
axios and he's use the mounted function
again so
mounted this dot get
project oops
methods get
products like that
and the first thing i want here is to
get the categories log from the url
we are on and i also want to get
the products like before i do anything
more here i just want to import this
page into the router so we can visit it
and see that everything is working
and i want to add one more product here
which can be an object just so things
here will work and not crash the site
if i now go to router you see here that
you have the home page
and the about page but we now want to
import
the product page we just created so
import
project from dot slash views
slash project dot view
then we want to append it at the bottom
here because
this has the same url structure as a
project
but we want to use dynamic routes and
that's best to have at the bottom
so create a new object this part
and here is a slash colon category
slug this is the name of the parameter
slash colon product slog
so just easier to separate the slopes
from each other
name project
and the component we're going to use is
product
which we imported here a component and
page is almost the same thing
and save so everything here seems to be
okay
so for now go to the home page to
replace the view details
label with the button like that
now we have a router link and we bind it
to attribute called
to and here we pass in
the product that get absolute url which
we get from the backend
the button is dark and has empty force a
little bit space
above the button so if we save this
now go back you see this turn into
button
and at the bottom of the left screen you
will see winter slash
warm jacket if i click it
get an error because this does get
product is not a function
okay if i go back to product.view
this should be get product just refresh
okay so there's no errors perfect if you
see these warnings here i'm going to fix
this later it's just because the winter
the category and
login similar doesn't exist yet
so now we need to continue this and get
the product
excels dot get
slash api v1 and
to get the products we now say products
then we want to pass in the cat node
products log but first the category slug
dollar sign curly bracket like that
slash dollar sign curly bracket
and this but this formatting doesn't
work
if you use this regular quotes so we
need to
replace it with this
like that so now we get the correct url
and then we will get the new response
back from the server and then we can
just say this dot
product equals response dot data
and if there are any errors you just
console log
errors you can show it in the console if
you want to know what error is
so if we save now go back here
refresh okay there's an error
dot done is not defined sorry i forgot
to add the dot
refresh and now we got information from
the servers now we have the image
title description and also the price
if i go back to the front page now click
this product
instead it everything here has changed
perfect so now
i can set this to done this to dawn
and this to done great done
next now is to set up the view x or
state management
we need this to make it possible to add
things to the cart
for authentication and a lot of other
things
so if you now go back and find store
index.js i have already created a store
this comes
default from view state is the
variables or informations mutations is
synchronous mutation students variables
because you can't just
change them directly actions will be
asynchronous function to change it
modules i'm not quite sure
so inside here we create a new couple of
new products
so in here we create a new so in here we
created
a couple of new properties first we
create a new object called
cart and inside there we have one list
called
items and then we have is authenticator
we can just set it to false so it's done
and same with the token this will be
used later when we add
login and it's loading set defaults
because we want to show a loading bar
when we're going
between products anything into the cards
in my cart and similar
i can just save this and i can set this
to done because
that's actually setting up the store
like that
so now we need to make it possible to
add things to the cart and then we need
to add some functionality to view x
and we do that inside the mutations
first i want to create a function called
initialize store
this is so we can store things in the
local storage
of the webs of the browser
first we check if the local storage
exists
with an item called cart and if it
doesn't we just create it
and if we get it from the local storage
we can state.cart
which is this json.parse and then we get
the object from the local storage but if
it doesn't exist we need to create
it and then we say local storage
dot set item cart which is the name of
the object and then we stringify
this object
and then one more add
to cart state and here we want to pass
in the item we want to add to the cart
first we create a new variable called
exists
so here we check if the item we are
trying to add to record
exists in the chord from before
so we add a test here if exists that
line so
if it's larger than zero then we know
that item is already in the course
so we get the first object in this list
since it's already in a list i just do
it like this
as a quantity parse end
get the quantity and add
the quantity we try to add from the
this form here so this is a 10 there
it's increased by 10
but if it's not in the card you need to
add it to the cart
and to do that we just state.court.items
to
push the item and so all of the
information we get
will just be pushed right into the cart
and then we say local storage set item
cart
and then we stringify the whole object
so the next time if you just refresh the
browser now everything will be stored to
the next time
perfect so then
i can set this to done initialize the
store
in app.view so then i need to go back to
app.view
because the first time or yes when we go
into the page we want to
make sure that the store and cart is
existing
so in here i created one object called
cart so i have it available in this
template because we're going to use it
up in the menu
and just like we have a hook called
mounted we also have something called
before create so before this is created
we want to initialize the store and to
initialize the store we say this
dot store dot commit initialize store
commit is used to call the actions
we have here no the mutations not the
actions
so if i just go back here now we now
initialize the store and we can create
or and we can close the before create
so then i can set this to done
and then i just want to show the card
length up in the menu
so if i go back to app.view again
and scroll up here after the chord
we said that two parenthesis and chord
total length
this is a computed value and just like
we have methods
and variables similar we have something
here called
computed these are calculated
variables based on things around on the
whole page
so we want to create one called a cart
total length
and every time the car changes this will
also automatically update
first you create a new variable let
total length
set it to zero now we want to loop
through
all of the items in the chord
and for each iteration we just say total
length
plus equals this dot chord items dot
quantity
return total length and
save if we now go back here you'll see
that we don't have anything in the cart
so then we need to make sure that when
we click this this is
updated automatically so if you see here
now
in the to list we have add we already
have this button but we need to
make it possible to call
the the store with ux
so if i just go here say add click
add to cart and i can copy this
go down to methods and below the get
product i create it like this
first i checked that the the the value
inside this.quantity
which is the field a pair actually is a
number
and if it isn't the number i just set it
to one
if anyone has managed to changed it
somehow
and then i create a new object const
item
product which is set to the product we
are on
and the quantity is a reference to the
quantity up here
and then to call the store we just said
this dot store dot commit
add to cart and plus n item
so if you now go back to here we call
this
function and pause in item and this code
will execute
so if you now just refresh add to cart
that did not work okay
console.log add
card just test that this actually is
clicked
on yes so
why isn't this working pass
in this product the quantity
okay so i think i forgot to do one thing
and that is
inside mounted hook on the upper view
i just said this dot cord equals distort
store dot card because the
card total length calculates this
so now you see five there and if you
click one more it also
increases so now it's working there
perfect
so then i can go back to the
product.view just to remove
this comment and next
i want to make it possible to show the
little uh
pop-up saying that you have added the
product to the cart
and to do this i just need to stop view
here
and install a new package called npm
install
bulma toast
and now we can say mpn run serve again
and go back to vs code and first
at the top here below axios as i import
curl bracket toast from bulma toast
and inside here below at the bottom
we have added the product to record we
call toast
set the message we want to show the type
which is class which will show a green
it's dismissable pause on hover duration
which is 2000 milliseconds
and bottom right of the screen and save
so if i now click here again so refresh
click the product was added to the cart
great now i have added to cart
functionality
and i can set this task to done i just
want to
move these tasks a little bit because i
want them
below here below there
so now i want to implement a loading bar
so when we click
product and things go slow between the
server
i want to show a loading bar so you know
what's going on
so if i go into store you know
remember that we added this but you need
to make it possible to change this
so i create a new action here or
mutation
so set is loading so we just
pause in false or true from the
one of the pages and then
if i can go to product for example
and at the top of this function
i can say this dot store commit so now
we set
set is loading to true and when this
excels is finished
we can say false like that
but to make sure that we don't call
false before it's finished we need to
set this to a sink
and a wait so
when this is finished this code will
execute
and save so nothing will happen now
because we haven't added the loading bar
to the screen yet
so if i just go to app.view
scroll up above this section
create a new div is loading bar has
text center and bind this clause
attribute and set is loading if
state is loading is set to true
so if this is set to true the loading
wire will show
and here i just add a div class lds dual
ring and we need to add some styling to
this
so if i just go down at the bottom and
find the style object
i've already prepared this so we set
lds dual ring display inline block width
and height
is set to 80 and then after this we had
content
empty set display block set width and
height of the circle to 64.
more genus 8 border radius and the color
i will add this to the github so you can
easily get it from there if you don't
want to write all of this yourself
then we set the keyframes because we
wanted to go down
up and circle or rotate
we set this automatically to hidden and
height to zero
but when we overloading the height is
set to 80.
so we save this so if you save this now
go here refresh you see this here a
little bit while we wait for information
from the server
so now we have a loading bar
set this to done and if i want to use
this other places
like the front page i can do that just
copy that line
find where we are loading this a sync
and set it to await
true and false
i could set it in here but if we got an
error then we need to
set it to false in there as well so it's
just easier to show it
or remove it after so for now front
refresh you see this very fast
great so then we can continue
to make a possible to set the document
title
because as you can see here it says
check gets view and we want to
make it possible to click a product i
want to say
black no brown leather instead of just
jackets view which
doesn't make any sense so if i
for example can go to project.view
and after i've got the product from the
server
i can set document.title
this.product.name
and pipe it into jackets like that
and the front page you can set this in
the mounted
here you can just say
home like that save so if you now
refresh you will see
brown leather pipe jackets if i go to
the front page it says home
great so this will be implemented all
pages we create from now on
so i can set this as well to done
so now i want to make it possible to
click winter and summer appear because
now nothing happens when i go to these
pages
so the first thing i need to do is to go
back to views.pi
and create a new view set for the
category so just category detail just
like here
and i can copy most of this
just paste it remove products like
okay and instead of saying product area
of course a category because we want to
get the category
not the product i can remove the
filter as a slug is
category slug and the same
with this one can be copied
and get remove the product slug
remove the product slug and here we want
to use something called a category
serializer which you are going to create
very soon
copy and paste and save so now we have
the view sets but we need to create the
serializer for this as well
so below the product serializer
we create a class called category
serializer and pause in this
one more time then we say class matter
model equals category and then the
fields we
want to use is id name
slug and we also want to get all of the
products connected to
this category and to make sure that we
get all the data connected
to the product as well i can pass in
products
equals product serializer and then money
equals true
and i will use this product serializer
to get the data and pass it in here as
well
and i can copy to get absolute url
i don't need the slug actually because i
get it in here
save then we need to import it here
so we just pot products
slug category slug
views dot category detail dot s
view and that's it for the back end
so if you now go down to view again we
need to create a page for showing the
category
so here's the new file category.view
so begin template div class
page category close it
script name is category
oops category and i know we're going to
use xco so
import excels from
excels and i want to show the toast if
you get any errors we're going to show
the information that we got an error
from the server
and in here is data return
create a new object called category and
a list called products inside there
and up in the template you also want a
div
to show the title and the product inside
there
so it's just like the latest product
this is size 2 hashtag center
and just category.name i'm about to get
the category
from the back end we create there go
into the mounted hook
mounted and call this.getcategory
and now we need to create this function
methods
get category and we can set this to a
sync as well because we want to use the
loading bar here also
but first we can get the categories like
from the route
parameters just like we did in the
detail page for the
project then we can set the is loading
to true
and to false defaults after excel's
request axios
dot get and here i just pass in the
route
to the category use this one
inside there dot then
response
create a fat arrow function this dot
category equals response dot data
and here we got the category and also
the products
and when we get this from the server you
can set the document title to
this.category.name
pipe jackets and if there are errors you
just say catch
error console.log
printed in there but since we have the
toast available we can show
something went wrong please try again
and then you show a red information
so now everything there is okay but we
still need to show the products
but we can first import it to the router
below here import category
from dot slash views category.view
i can make a copy of this it will be a
little bit simpler
because we don't need product slug we
can just have it like this
remove the trailing slashes category
category okay so
i have an error in the python code
name category is not defined
and that's inside the views.pi
sorry i forgot to import the
category model of course
for now refresh something went wrong i
getting 500 error from the server
let's check it out what that can be
category serializer
forgot to import that as well sorry
save refresh now we get summer but we
don't have any product
to show there yet but if i go to the
front page
to home.view i can just
make a simple copy of this code
go to category.view paste
but instead of saying latest product is
category dot
products and save and then they show
there
but the problem now is that we are uh
we are duplicating a lot of the code so
this should actually be turned into a
component
and that is the next task in the list i
think
yes convert product to a component
so inside the folder components we can
create a new file
product box dot view so this can be
reused
all over the page so i can just paste
the same code this is the code from the
front page
if class column is tree we just remove
the v4
and then script name product
books and we need a way to post
information from the parent
down to the component and then we use
something called props
and i have one props here called product
which is an object
so if you try to send in anything else
you'll get an
error and then the last thing
is to go to home and i can just
remove this code
go back to the product box because i
just want it in here
so it's just connected to this component
so if we save now we should be able to
reuse this code
so in home dot view we can go to the top
here
and say import product box
from at slash components
that is just a shortcut for the root
folder of the view project
and product box like that
and to be able to use it here we need to
add it
to the list of components and
then i want to remove all of this
and replace it with this much prettier
code sorry one too many dips there
so now we just say product box use the
same v4
but here we should latest test
products bind it and we bind
product to the product we get here
and pause it into the prop here so it
can be used here as well
if i go back to the front page it still
looks the same but
the code is reused so i can do the same
for the category page if i go back to
home
copy this
like that go to category and then i just
paste it in there then i just need to
import it
import product books from
at components slash product books
and then just register here components
like that and save so now it's much
easier to maintain
oops typo components
so if i now go here
there is something wrong latest product
sorry
did another typo here it should say
category
dot products save
so now we have the same code on all
pages
but if you look closely now if i click
summer
winter nothing happens and this is
because we need to watch
the route for changes because when we
switch between two similar
dynamic routes the life cycle hooks
won't be cold
so when i click the winter or summer
the mounted hook will not be
be clicked or refreshed
from view so we need to fix this so
below
mounted i create a new object called
watch so this will watch changes to the
route
and here we can check that if to
the right we're going to is a category
then we call this
here function again so if we now click
save
refresh and i click winter the products
change
the title and similar great
so now everything there is okay
so now we have the possibility to view a
category
to get this to done and then we want to
make it possible to search we want to
add a simple search bar up in the menu
and then the first thing you need to do
is to add some a new view
so first you need to import something
more from the rest framework
because we need a decorator here here i
want to use a
simple function best views instead of
the class-based views
and here we use the decorator api view
and we say that we just
want to accept post requests to this
view
search which is the name of this view
and then we get the query from the
request data and if it's empty it's
empty
but if query we want to check if it is
empty
and then we say product equals prodigy
product dot object
filter and we check if the name contains
the query or if the description
contains the query so you just need to
import this
q function from django which means you
make it possible to do a little bit more
advanced query sets to import it we can
scroll up
and just at the top here we say from
django.db.models import
queue you can go down and continue
and then we just want to use the same
serializer the product serializer and
pass in
products return and just copy this line
like that and if the query is empty
we can just return an empty products
list
and save and then i just want to import
this to the urls
so at the bottom oh sorry i can be above
here
since this is a fixed word and not a
slug
so then we go to slash products search
to get information from the server
okay so now we have the route so then we
can go back to view and continue the
development there
so if i just find app dot view
scroll up and above the nav bar and i
want this to be on the other side of the
menu
to do that i create a new div class app
bar starts
then a new dave claus with navbar item
and then a formatter get action slash
search
slash search is here on view and not on
the back end we should get back to you
soon
and just like the field has add-ons we
have it here as well just like on the
add to cart button
and at first control input text class
input
placeholder what you're looking for and
give it the name of
query
whoops looks weird
okay like that's around the button close
button is success
in here we have icon which is just a
search icon
if it's saved now go back here
you will see that we have the simple
search here with this icon from front
awesome
so then we can create the search page
which you to go to and click this to
create a new view
search dot view create a new template
and a difficult page search
and script tag name
search and now i'm going to use
excels here and i can import the product
box like on the front page and the
category page because the product box
will also be used here
i can create a data array return
products this can be a list
and then components so we register the
product books here
and i also want one more product no
property here called query
and when we open this we're going to
mount it
and we can set the document title to
search
and then a pair create some more html
this is a div class columns is a
multiline
and then we have a div for the title and
information about which search
term you have searched for
so search and then search term this will
just print
the contents of this variable
close the div close that div
and then below here we can call this
component again and just loop through
just like on the other two pages
so if we save now we can import this to
the router
so just test it it's working
import search
from dot slash views search dot
view and then again add it to the list
here
okay copy this one paste it above
there search
paste there and search and save
so you can now go back here i can say
check it
hit enter search term is empty so
there's something wrong
or something i have forgotten to do yes
in the mount that here we need to get
information from the url
like that so then we get the location
search substring they get all of the
parameters
based on this url and then we can get
the query
from the url then we said this.query
which is a reference to this
to the value of the query in the url
and then we can set this dot perform
search
like that okay just create this
functionality so we have it
methods perform search
save so even now go back here you'll see
that they have jacket in there because
that's what what we were searching for
now we can set this to a sync because we
want to use the loading bar here as well
true false after the axios
so here is the evade excels and then we
use dot post because we want to post the
query back to the server
to this route which we created and then
when we get the response we can just add
this.product
equals response.data save
and if you go back now you will see that
we got this back from the server
your search brown instead we should get
a brown leather jacket
perfect so now we have a simple search
for
our store which means we can go back
here
so this task done great
so now we can make it possible to go to
the cart so we can see what we have in
there it
possible to increment and decrement the
content and similar
but we can start by creating a new view
chord dot view create template tag
tab class page cart
close it script
name cart now we can just import this to
the router before we continue so it's
done
make a copy of one of these cards
card and i can copy and paste here as
well
chord chord chord and save
so then i can click here we rewrite it
here but there are no contents yet but
we're going to fix that
now so if i go back here i can add
the title and div class column
so if i save now you will see that we
have the title there so everything
is working as it should up until now at
least
and then below the title i create a new
deep clause
and add a d plus shadow so it's a little
bit the shadow around this contents
and then i add a simple table
set it the full width so it fills out
the whole screen
and this will only show if there are
products
in the cart and if there are not you can
see here we say
we if you use that directive and down
here is a vls
so if you don't have any products we
show this information instead
and the table contains the product price
quantity
total and the symbol empty one for the
actions
here we're going to use a component
we're going to create very soon
where we just loop through cart dot
items
so if you go down here i can import
xios from xcos
and i can import this cart item we're
going to create i just want to
make something more here data
return cart
an object and set the empty list in
there so the code up here don't crash
and then i can say components
so we register this with view
and save so now we just want to create
this before we continue
so up here in the components folder
cart item dot view create a template
script name cart
item and here we want one prop
called initial light time because we
don't want to change the item we get in
so we need to
create a new item m and pass it in back
later you will understand very soon
then we create a new data object which
just returns the item
and our set the item to the property we
get from the parent
and we have one method called get item
total let's just take the quantity and
multiply it with the product
price and if you just go up here to the
template again
paste in a little bit of code first we
have a td with
router link which is connected to the
product
get absolute url just like in the
product
box here and then we just show the
product name
below there we have the product price
the item quantity
and then we use this get item total
which is the method we created here
for calculating the total price to fixed
so it's not
very many decimals here and then add a
button which is not going to work yet
but if we save this go back to the cart
you don't have
any products in the cart but that's
because we haven't activated
this yet so we can create the mounted
who care again
like this this dot card equals list
store
just like we did in app.view so if we
save now
go back still don't have any products
that's wrong because we have eight up
here
i think it is because uh this value
hasn't been set yet this is a
computed value so add a new property
here
computed card total length
and then we use something called reduce
which is the built-in function in
javascript
so we loop through all of the functions
no
items there this is the accumulator and
current value
and then we just combine them to each
other
and default value is zero so it just
takes zero and plus
every time there is a quantity so if we
save now
now we see the contents here perfect so
that means that
this function is working as it should
like it's just the this
value is going up there and then for
every time we go
through at item it's adding the item
quantity
okay and below here i want to create a
button for going to
the checkout and also showing the totals
so below here
paste in the code div class column is 12
and box so i have a little bit shade
around that too
give this subtitle summary and then we
create a new
get total price which is a new computer
value i'll come back to
just to show the total price and then
the number of items we have
and then below there we have a button to
cart slash checkout which will come back
to you very soon
so i can just scroll down this function
is
very similar to the total length just
that it takes the price
and multiplied with the quantity instead
so if we save now
go back here you'll see that the total
is showing here and that you have eight
eight times in the cart
great so now we can go back here
to the to-do list and set this task to
done
and the cart item is already a component
perfect so now i want to make it
possible to click plus
and minus to change the quantity and the
card and also click the delete button to
remove it totally or completely from the
course
okay so to make it possible to change
the quantity we go back to
curve.view and then just below
oh sorry we're going to cart item so
it's easier to handle it there in the
component
so below item quantity we are decrement
quantity
and increment quantity
plus so then we're going to create these
two functions
as well item
and increment
quantity there press an item like that
now we have the plus and minus button
but nothing happens when i click this
but that will be fixed now
so when we click increment quantity you
say in
item dot quantity plus one and then we
call
this dot update card and when we call
decrement quantity is a minus
equals one but i also want to check that
if the quantity is zero then we just
want to remove it completely from the
cart
so we can't go below one without it
being removed from the cars
then we can create this update cart
so we can update back to the parent
and when we call update card we just say
local storage to the set item
cart and then just stringify the whole
object of cart which we have
in the storage and since we already here
we can create a remove
from cart as well this will call
a function back to the parent and make
that
remove it from the object because we
can't do it directly from here since
we're in the component
so let's just add the button for this as
well
so if i go up now just replace this
button
[Music]
where we add add click remove from cart
pass in
item and then it's this function that
will be called
so if i click this now it go down as you
can see down
in the left here in the summary the
price changes
if i refresh that process and everything
has been updated
perfect but if i click this now it won't
uh
work because we haven't done anything to
this
so what we need to do now is to just
copy this and go to
cart dot view and at the next line is a
v
on so we listen to remove from chords
and we just say remove from cart
and then we need to create this function
so this
is from the from the component and this
is in the chord dot
view so i just scroll down below
no sorry methods let's create a new
property and then i have a function
called
remove from cart
in here i said that this dot card dot
items equals this dot corted items and
then we filter out
the product we get and remove it from
that list
and save if i refresh now click
this one it was removed from the card
and the prices here was also updated
perfect so then i can actually set this
to done because now we have made
both of these two possible okay so now
it's time to make it possible to
sign up and log in when you proceed to
the cart or
sorry the checkout okay so first we can
start by creating the view for this
so sign up dot view
create a new template live close page
sign up
and script name sign
up and i'm going to use axios here so
import axios from
xcos oops
and i want to use the toast if there are
an errors in the sign up form
then i have a data object with the
username password
and i repeated password and a list of
errors if there are any
and inside here i had one more dip class
columns
and then column is four is offset fourth
it's narrow and on the middle of the
screen close that
close that and then we can import it to
the router just to see that it's working
router make a copy of one of these
sign f
i can copy the search for example
sign up sign
up sign up
and then i don't have any buttons for
this yet but if i try to go to sign
up instead i'll see the title at least
below here i want to have a forum we're
filling out all of the information we
need
so just go back to signup.view
and below the title here add form
and when we submit this i want to
prevent the default action which is to
submit it to the
server we call a function called submit
form
we can create this so we have it down
here
like that then i want to add a few more
fields
up here first i have a div class field
and a label username
and a v model username which just
returns or
is connected to this one and then below
the username
i have two fields for the password which
is password and password two
so i can check that they're matching and
similar
and if there are any errors i want to
use something called div class
notification so we can show information
there
and print out error to the user and this
will
only generate or be rendered if the
errors has
length and if there is we loop through
them and show them as a simple paragraph
then have a simple button to submit the
form
and if you already have an account you
can just click here to
log in we can go back and see it now so
we
have the three fields the button or
click here to log in
but we don't have haven't created that
yet
so now i just want to create a
functionality for signing up
remember that everything is done in the
backend so it's just here in the front
end we need to change
things okay so the first thing i want to
do is to
reset distort errors in case you try to
sign up multiple times
and then we can validate the username
just to check that it's not
empty and if it is empty we
push this string to the list of errors
if we save now
first just click sign up you see this
username is missing
and then we do the same for the password
but you just check password one
and down here we check that if they
don't match
and if there are no errors now we can
continue and push the information to
the server and say if this.there is
not this.length then we can go into this
first we create the object with the
username and the password which is
information that will be sent
to the server and then we say excels
i want to use the post so we call post
to this route and pass in the forum data
then we get the response back from the
server
and we show a toast with the information
that the account is created so go
please go and log in and then we use
distort router push
to automatically redirect you to the
login screen
and the error list here is a little bit
longer than we are used to
we loop through the errors we get from
the server and just push it
so if you have problem with that the
username already exists
and similar you will show it here okay
so now we can save
and we can try to create an account code
with
stein
sign up account was created and i got an
error at the same time
okay i got an error because the login
here doesn't
exist yet yes i get that category does
not exist so i need to create the
in login page
so that is the next task anyway so i can
just
set this to done because i got the new
account but there is an error because
the login page doesn't exist
so create a new file log in dot
view and if i just go here now to the
router we can import it
log in
and just copy this
log in log in
and save so if we now refresh we don't
get any errors there so now we can
continue and build the login
functionality
so for now just go back up to login.view
paste a little bit of code it's almost
identically to the sign up page you can
just copy that
and remove password to and change the
login or sign up to login besides that
it's identical
i can create the script and we can
import
excels we can set the name to log
in and we can create the data array
with username password a list of errors
mounted document.title
log in pipe it into jackets
save so now the title is set up there
and i have the simple login form
perfect so but before i continue and
make it possible to call the backend i
just need to
change the store view x a little bit
so in here below the initialize
store i add this because i want to
check if you have a item called token in
the local storage
and if you do we set token this object
there to that value
and is authenticated is true and reset
them if they are not
apparent in there and then we need a
function to set
the token very simple
just said token and pass in token and
then
we set authenticated to true and the
value of token to
token and the same with remove token
when we log out we just want to reset
these two
so you're not don't have any problems
there
i can save this close it for now
and when we call the initialize store
inside app.view
i need to make a few small changes there
as well
first i want to get the token from the
state
so we know all the time if you are
authenticated or not and in here we say
if token so if you are authenticated we
want to set the access default headers
or authorization token to the token we
have stored in the browser
and if not we set authorization to to
empty
and save but then we can continue and
make the rest of the login functionality
so below the mounted we need the methods
for
creating the login function or the
submit
form
here i want to call async submit form
like that first i just want to reset
the authorization in case there are
anything that
from the an earlier session or similar
and i want to remove the token from the
local storage
and then i create a form that i just
like and sign up but
here i only have one password and then i
just paste
simple axios post which goes to token
login and we get the response back
because the new variable called token
with uh in the information from response
to data.org
token and then we call
the store to set the token with
information we get from the server
and we set the default header here to
token so that every time that we
call the server from now on we have
already set the token
and we store the tokul token in the
local storage so we can refresh and
everything will work
and after that we want to go to the part
where we're coming from
so if we were in the course and click
proceed to checkout
you would be redirected to the login
page and then
you'll go back there after and if there
are no it just be
redirected to the cart when you sign in
and here we just had a simple error just
like in the sign up now we can save
okay there's an error axios is not
defined
sorry i think it is in the update view i
forgotten to
import here import axios
from excels
and save so now refresh
i have this i can try to log in with the
user i just created
log in and yes i was redirected to the
cart so
hopefully and probably everything was
working there now so now i authenticate
that as code it's time user
so then i can go to the to-do list
and i can set this task to done
and i want the simple my account page
where i can make it possible to log
out
so if i just go into views there
creating a file my account dot view
created template and
script name my account
and we have a simple method here for
logging out
this is just a function logout and we
reset this
we remove everything from the local
storage and we commit
remove token so the state is also
updated
and when that's done we redirect the
user back to the front page
of the store or the e-commerce website
the template here is very simple it's
just a david glass page
my account and i have the title my
account
with the button where we when you click
that you call the logout function
and it's just a button with this danger
so it's red and it's easier to
understand what it does
okay so now there's a little bit of
magic we need to do
in the router because we need to add
something called a router guard now
because
if you go to my account without being
authenticated we want to send you to the
login page
so first we can import this my account
and just add it here
my account my
account like that so now it's
just like the other but we need to
append some metadata here so you can
tell
view that we want this to be guarded by
authentication
so meta object require login equals true
and to make this happen we need to
scroll down at the bottom here
we will create the router so before we
go into that route we want to check
in the state if we are authenticated
so below here we say router dot before
each so before each route we go into we
we want to loop through this code so
this is a little bit complicated but we
checked that if to dot match some record
require login so this will trigger when
this
is set to true and not store.state
is authenticated so if you require
login and you're not authenticated we
want to send you to the login screen
and then we say next name log in
which is the page a query just so we
know we're
going to redirect you to after
else i can just call a function called
name
and then we go to the my account page so
if i now go to
my account you're probably here
okay here is an error store is not
defined i forgot to import
store in the page in the index.js here
so at the top here i can say import
store from dot
store and save so if i now refresh you
will see that my account
page and i can log out access is not
defined
forgot to import it of course
import excels from excels
save refresh logout and that was logged
out
great try to log in again call it's time
like that great so now we have login
functionality log
out and sign up perfect
so i should probably change this because
we don't want to see the login button
or authenticator will much rather go and
show
my account button that's not very hard
to achieve
so i just need to find app.view
and then where i have the login button
create
paste some new code here we create a new
template
and check if you are authenticated and
we want to show the my account button
if not we show the login button so if i
just
save now go back here using my account
instead of login
perfect okay so next step now is to
proceed to the checkout
where you need authentication and that
we have already fixed authentication so
we can create a new page
for the checkout so in here
create a new file checkout.view okay so
first we create a new template
with the page checkout multiline and the
title
as usual oops close the div
close the div and close the template
and create the script name
check out like that
the dead object here is a little bit
longer because here we have the cart
stripe card and all of the
information of the customer and
the list of errors
then we want to go into mounted as a
document.title
equals check out
jackets and we want to set the court
here
to this so we get information from the
state
in to this one also and we need a method
for getting the total
of the cards
or get the item totals already so for
each item we get the total of
the item and then i have copied
the two computer values from the cart
page
so they are identical
and then i just want to import excels
before i forget it
import excels from excels
and then we can just changes to the
template
first we create a new box with a simple
table inside
where we show the items product price
quantity and the total
so here we also add the body to the
table
your looped record.items and set the key
to
product id here so the product name
price quantity and i'm used to get item
total that
created down here and then i want a
simple foot
for the table where you show the total
length
the total price and similar so if you
save this now we can go
into router to import it here
check out like that
and now i want to copy this because i
want to require
login when you go to this page and i
want it below here
so i'll connect it to the cart and the
url is cart slash checkout
the name is checkout
check out
safe like that so now we have the
possibility to go there
so if we go now here proceed to check
out but you don't have any products
there so we can
fix that first add the cart
go here proceed to checkout and now we
have the
summary here of what we are going to pay
perfect
now we need to add four below here we
add information like the name
phone number etc so
then i can go back to the checkout page
and below this div i think yes
create one more div with the subtitle
shipping details
close that div that looks okay and all
fields here are required to fill out
and then below this i had a div class
multiline because i want
the some fields there and some next to
them so we don't have a very long form
first i had the fields to the left the
first name
b model first name which is connected to
this
down here and then the last name
the email which is type email so we have
a validation
from the browser and the phone
and then the field on the right side
will be address
zip code and place so if i save now
and go back you'll see that i have much
more hair
perfect but we need a button and a place
to fill in stripe
and if you get any errors from the
server
or from view you want to show them here
so it's just like other places where
we're shown errors
hr just add a div
element id card this is for stripe i'll
come back to that
soon and then we check that if the
card.length is more than zero then we
want to show the button where you can
pay with stripe then i just need to
create this function so it doesn't crash
like that if i save now
go back you'll see pay with stripe great
actually i think this is supposed to be
one
more div out i'll just cut this out
paste it there so now yes that looks
much better
so here we'll it'll be possible to add
the fields for stripe
soon so i just want to
extend this a little bit before we go
further to the next task
paste in a little bit of code first i
just reset this errors list
then i check if the first name is filled
out and etc of
all of the different fields so we just
save now
try to submit you'll get information
that all of the fields are missing
but now we have a simple checkout page
at least
so then i can set this task to done
and then i can create a simple success
page before i forget it
so just find the views folder here
create new file called success dot view
template script name
success i can set the amount add to
success
jackets and the template will just show
that your order will be processed within
48 hours
whatever you want to show here to the
customer
save and close then we can import it
to the router so it's done
so router index.js
success like that
so go down here
card slash access success
like that so now we have the simple
variable redirected to
when the payment is done like that
okay so then i just need to make sure
that the
that the stripe is working in the back
end
so that's a little bit more job so
if you haven't created an account that's
stripe you need to do that
just go to stripe.com it's free and then
you get the
api keys you need and when you're done
that
you can go back to the settings.pi file
and create
a variable there i like to have it up
here somewhere
and it's stripe secret game and it's a
very long and you need this test key and
it's important that it is the secret key
which you're going to use in the back
end and to keep track of the orders we
need a new django app
so if i just go down here stop the
server python
managed by start app order
and before i forget it i can just append
it to the list of installed apps
order save and close
and now we need a model to keep track of
the orders
so find order here go to models.pi
i want to connect the order to users and
it import
this object from django which is the
user object your
request you are authenticated with
then i want to import the product model
because the items
is connected to a product then i create
a new clause
order which is the order model and pause
in models dot
model and then to connect the user to
the order
i just create a new foreign key set the
related name to order so it's easy to
get
all the orders for a user then just
paste in all of this field which is the
contact information we are
going now we are passing in in the
checkout form
and i want one field for uh for the date
time field so i know when the order was
created and then i want the decimal
field so i know
the paid amount so i get this from
stripe and fill it out
just so i know that i can double check
it afterwards
and i also save the stripe token that
was used to perform the purchase
and i changed the ordering to create
that in descending order
so that in the back end everything is
okay and when you show the ordering and
then my account
page and then add a simple string
representation of the object which is
just the first name so it's easier to
see
in the back end and i want to order item
as a separate model as well
so clause order item
models dot model first i need a
reference to the order so
i just do like every other foreign case
and i need a reference to the product so
i know which item
which product it is on the item and then
the price so it's easier to get
i don't have to go through the product
to get it
and then the quantity which is defaults
to one
and then the stream string
representation which is just the id so
it's easier to see in the back end
so that's the models for there and then
i can update the database by running
make migrations
and migrate then i can run the server
again
great i can also close this and now we
have the models
okay so to make it possible to proceed
to the checkout
and everything is working in the back
end we need to go into
views slash no order slash use
pi and import a few things
first import strike which you're going
to use to talk to stripes api
and then we import settings so we can
get the
secret key we added to settings.pi
we need to get the user i need to use
http before if there are any errors and
then a simple
render and then you import a few
functions from the rest framework
like status authentication permissions
and
just like in the in the product slash
reviews.buy
then we import the two models we created
and
i also need to import the order
serializer
i want to come back to that and fix it
very soon
then i do create the api view and here
we just want to post requests
i set authentication because we want to
require token authentication
and that the user is authenticated then
we create a new view
called checkout and we want to use the
order serializer
with the data we get from the the
form we fill out in the checkout page
now we can say if serializer is valid
that means that
all of the data is correct and we can
proceed with the checkout
then we initialize stripe with the
secret key we get from the settings file
and then we can calculate the paid
amount by saying sum
and then we take the item quantity
and multiply with the price and we do
this for
every item in the serializer validated
that are items which you get from the
post form
and then we want to add a try here
because if
the payment isn't successful we need to
accept this and show an error to the
user
first we create a new charge for stripe
i set the amount to pay the amount and
multiply it with 100 because
the stripe wants this in cents and not
in dollars
i want to set the currency to us dollars
because that's what i want on my
e-commerce
and then i just show a simple
description which will show up on their
bills which is a charge from jackets
and source which is the stripe token we
get from the front end so that
everything
is connected and working
now just close this and when we go
go through this that means that
everything is working and we can save
the data in the serializer
set the user to request the user which
is the requested user and there's a paid
amount
to the paid amount we calculated up here
and then we return response as a 201
created so
the front end knows that everything is
okay
and accept exception so that means that
there is something
wrong and if there is something wrong we
need to show a 400 400 bed request
and the same goes with if there is
something wrong with the serializer we
just
show the same error and save
then i can create a new urls file for
the order
urls.pi from django.urls import
pot
not fromorder.notimport views and url
patterns equals credit list
part okay do it like this but
check out we use the checkout and the
name is also check out
don't think we need this but yes like
that
great and then we need to create a
serializer for
the order so inside this app
create a new file serializers.point
so first we import serializers from the
rest framework
and then we import the two models we
created and we want the product
serializer since it's connected to
and one of the items and then i create
the order item
serializer class matter
[Music]
model equals order
whoops order sorry order item this is
the order item this
has to be above the order serializer
and the fields i want for the order item
is price the product and the quantity
and then below here i create the order
serializer
plus model equals order
and the fields here i want id and all of
these names stripe token
and items and to get items i need to do
just like we did in the product for the
categories
so items equals order item serializer as
that manager
and what we need to do now is to
override the create functionality
for this serializer to do that we create
a new function here called
def create and here we get the validated
data
we remove the items from there and then
we create a new order
based on the validated data we get from
the form
and then we loop through all of the
items
in the list and we create a new order
item and set
the order which is a foreign key to that
item data and the product is already
included here
now you can save this so i think that if
i now go back here
and just fill out something here
play with stripe nothing is working
because i haven't created the
function here in the com knowing the
here we need to call axios
which i've already imported so i can
scroll down here
so below here i check again if the error
has length meaning that if there are not
errors we can go into this
and the first thing we do then is to set
is loading to true
and then we use this dot stripe i will
show you how to edit
create a token based on the chord
information
and when that's done if there are errors
we remove
is loading and then we show that there's
something wrong with stripe and paste
try again
and then we just show the error in the
console as well
but if there are no errors from the
backend with straight then we
continue to dysfunction call stripe
token handler
token so then we call this function
this has to be a sync function
first we create a new list called items
started to be empty and then we loop
through all the items in the court and
just do some changes here because that's
much better for the backend so you get
the price
finished and everything and then just
push the object
to the list of items then we created new
data
from new data object with the contact
information
all the items and the stripe token
let's try token is the one we get from
the back end
and when that's done below here
we call await excels and then we post it
to
slash checkout which just created here
sorry i need to before i forget it
i need to go into the main urls
and import it here order
like that sorry about that
so then i can go back to them check out
yes so then we call it and when that's
done we call
uh the store the view x clear card so
everything is clear there
and then we redirect the user to the
success page we created
and then we just remove the set is
loading
so now i just need to import stripe here
and make sure everything is okay
so i go up and find the mounted
below here i paste a little bit of code
so first here i checked that if this dot
card
total length which is the function we
have down here
computed if that is greater than zero
that means that we have products in the
cart and we can continue
so then we create a new function
no new instance of stripe and a new
instance of elements
and then we want to hide the postal code
from that stupid form
and then we mount it to the element we
added
up here then we just
as you can see here we have the stripe
and chord which is just two
empty objects
and the last thing we need to do now i
think it's the last is to import stripe
in the index.html file
so below the font awesome paste in the
stripe
url js.stripe.com
v3 i think if i now
refresh yes you can see that we can fill
out the card number
and things like that so
let's try this no sorry i need to do one
more thing
and that is to go into the store
and create the remove no clear cart
function so that just
clears the whole object and then remove
it from the local storage
now refresh and then the card number to
test this you can use 42 42 42 42 32 42
32 42
and then a date in the future and one
two three as
cvc pay with stripe so
thank you the process will in the order
will be processed within 48 hours
and if i go here it seems that you got
post so everything there is correct
and if i go to
order and into admin notify i want to
register this with the backend
from dot models import order
and order item admin dot site
register order i don't need to see the
order item
save so then if i go here
go to the front page go to orders you
will see that i have an order
and the paid amount the stripe token and
everything seems to be working
so we got success page and the stripe
has got its money
perfect and i want to show orders on my
account
page so then i need to create a new
serializer
so if i scroll up
and find the order serializer
i can copy this
and say my order item serializer
and this is where i want to use the
product serializer like that
because if not there will be a problem
when you post it and you
because somewhere you have the object
product assuming you have
id for the project and similar and then
you can make a copy of the order
serializer but you don't need a create
function
just copy it and go up here
say my order serializer and i want to
use
my order serializer there as well
and i want to get the paid amount here
as a
variable save
so everything is okay then i need to
create the view sets for this
so import my order serializer
and then at the bottom create a new view
sets
called clause orders list and then you
set authentication clauses and
permissions
and then we override the get because
here we only want to get the orders
where the user
is the request user which is the
authenticated
and we want to use my order serializers
and return the data to the front end
so we can save this we need to import
this
into the urls
so below checkout we just say pot orders
views orders list
as view and save so now it should be
possible to use this in the front end so
now if i find
my account and below this button
create an hr and then a new div class
column
subtitle my orders and i created a new
uh component order summary where it
posts in
information about the order then
i need to import this component which
will create soon
and i need a registered component
and then i want to use the mounted we
can set the document title
and when that's done we call a new
function called get my orders
and this is very similar just the
the normal axios to api slash v1 slash
orders
and i'm going to get it to slap
dish.orders to response.data
just need to make sure that we have a
data array as well
return orders
which is a list and then we can oops
forgot that comma there
then we need to create this file and
component
new file order summary.view
okay so here we have the template a div
class box
and the order title which shows also the
order id
i have a subtitle with the products and
the table which shows
all of the different products and here
we just loop through order load items
which you get because we use the my
order serializer which has items
included
down here we just say name order summary
we get a prop
order and we have two methods for
getting the total for the item and the
order total
length so if i save now and expect that
wait word
okay because i need to
go into my account again
this has to be such a sync of course
when i use elevate in here
so now i have the order here with the
products i've ordered a simpler
perfect and that was really coding are
going to do now
so now it's time to push this code to
live server
and start making impossible for other
people to find
my store so if i just go to the to-do
list
i can set this task to done and the
first thing i'm going to do is to deploy
the django part of this project i'm
going to create a server
and then start accessing it i'm
installing the software we need
so if i go to the browser and into
digitalocean
and i click create up in the corner here
i'm going to create a new droplet
i want to ubuntu 20.04
and i just want a basic shared cpu
and i can select regular intel and five
dollar because it's
going to be a very small server for
testing
i don't want any volumes it can be
located in amsterdam it's close to
norway
a little bit at least the network name
can be set to that i don't want any of
this yet
and password like that okay so now that
was okay
one droplet hostname can be just ubuntu
jackets
and create droplet
and now this is created and i just need
to wait for the server to start
okay so now it's just started i copy the
address
try to access it ssh
root at
yes permission denied
okay okay type the wrong password
like that so now i should be in perfect
and then i can go to to do list because
i created the server and exit it
and then i want to install the software
we need
so first i just want to update
everything so that all of the packages
and everything
is correct this can sometimes take a
little while
and then see the apt get upgrade this
will actually upgrade the packages and
not
just the connections to them
great so now everything is updated and
we can start installing some software
i'm going to install python 3 pip
python3 dev
lib.qs postgresql postgresql contract
and nginx
just type that hit enter and yes i want
to install that
great and i also want to install cert
bot and python 3 insert bot
and insert but no patent reserve with
nginx so we can
get sl ssl certificates for the website
so yes
i will add all of these commands in a
file on github
okay so now that this does the done the
next is to create a postgresql database
so go back to server as i sudo dash you
postgres psql so i change which user i'm
logged in with
then i create a new database by saying
create database
jackets and i create a new user
jacket user with packet jacket's
password
and then i need to do some changes this
is for the role and
something to do with the configuration
for django
and then i want to grant all of the
privileges to this user
to that database and then i quit by
saying
backslash q so now we have postgresql
installed and the database is set up
with the user we can use
then i want to upgrade pip just so i
know that that
is also for with the newest version
and i want to install virtual
environment so we can use that
just like we do locally and then i want
to create a new folder
in web apps slash check cache which we
should read a
base for all of the projects here we can
go into it
then i want to create a user group for
the user
i'm going to call the group web app so
we can use the server for multiple
web apps or web applications or django
websites
then i want to create a user by saying
sudo user ad
system group id so i want to put it in
the web apps
set the default shell and the home
folder to web
slash jacket under the name of the user
which is
jackets hit enter and since i'm already
in this folder i want to create the
virtual environment by saying virtual
env
environment 382 and hit enter
and then i can go into it saying cd
environment
also i don't have to go into it but i
can activate it
environment bin activate
so now it's activated here just like it
is locally
and then i want to install the same
packages here that we have locally
and to do that i can go back to visual
studio code stop the server
as i pipped freeze
then i will get the list of all of the
packages we have installed
locally so if i just copy all of this
now
create a new file here called touch req
dot
txt vi or q
and paste it in there and i can install
of
all of them saying pip install r
req.txt now note that we have the same
packages
on the live server as you have locally
so that means that there are no
differences
in the environment for python and i need
to install
another pip which is cycle pg2 binary
this is used to
connect the django to the postgresql
server
next step now is to move the django
files from
locally to the server normally i would
just use
git but to make it easy i can just use
i can just send them by using scp
so here i go up one folder and say
sip or check go
jackets django
dot zip check at django
now i've got a folder with all of that
and i can send it by saying sap
r so root at
and then i p like that
sorry i forgot to specify which folder i
wanted to send
django jackasjango.zip
like that so now it should be sent here
and then just make this a little bit
smaller
cpu root
put it there and then i just say unzip
jackets jungle can it install
unzipped
and then i can unzip it great just
removed
a zip folder just to make sure that i
don't have any problems with the
the permissions for the folders and
similar if i do this you will see that
the root is owning everything here now
and i want it to be owned by the jackets
user
so ca mod ch
phone sorry dash r
jackets colon web apps
dot ls lord again and then you'll see
that
now i own all of the files and folders
so don't any
permissions wrong there or anything like
that
but i want to make a little change to
the cd jackets
and into jackets jungle i want to copy
the settings file because i want the
separate settings file for the
production
so this would be called settingspro.pi
and settings prod change the database
here
just remove these lines
and then i paste information about the
postgresql server we created
so by the name of the user know the
database
the username password and localhost
because
i'm the same server as the postgresql
great so now we need to update the
database but to do that i need to make a
copy
of the manage.pi
i should buy how to create a profile for
this as well
and h prod because i want to use the
prod file for updating the database
so now i can say python management pi
make migrations
sorry manage
prod by make migrations
and migrate
so now everything should be updated and
created in the back end
perfect next step now is to install
g unicorn g unicorn will be the web
server for django
so pip install g unicorn
i want to go up one folder and inside
the environment i want to create a
script for
running the g unicorn server so vi
environment
bin g unicorn underscore start
and then i paste in some code i set the
name to check its django
the directory for django socket file it
should be created automatically
which user to use which group which
settings module to use
and i would use the wsgi as i mentioned
in the beginning of this tutorial
and then just go into the django there
start something
and execute it
i will add the these files in the github
so you can get them there if you want
and then you need to make this run the
ball by saying chmod
plus x environment then unicorn
start you can try to run it
supposed to be jackets here
check it like that maybe that will work
now
no cd slash
web apps check it environment
jackets okay now i know why
it should be like this because the
jacket django is not
in the environment folder okay now it's
starting
the problem was that if i go into the
script again
add the wrong part here because you need
to go back
one folder and then into the environment
then bin then activate
and the same down here so now the
unicorn is starting
perfect next step is to install
something called supervisor
supervisor will make sure that the t
unicorn script is running at all times
so install supervisor by saying apt
install supervisor
and when that's done we can create a
script or just a config file that will
make sure
that the unicorn is running at all time
so if you go to cd e2c supervisor
conf create a new file touch
jackets dot conf
vi gen gets [ __ ] of course
that's not correct that will fix it
create new program
jackets django the command we want to
run is
webs slash jacket environmentary a2 bin
g unicorn which is the great script we
just created
we want to use the jackets
check gets its name of the user
and then a log file here i need to
create
this folder and then it's just some
environment configurations
so okay there so i have the log file and
then we need to update supervisor by
saying supervisor
re-read first
just to check that it's available
supervisor ctl
it's available of course and then update
and now it was added to the group if i
now
say status
it says starting now it says running so
now
hopefully django should be running in
the background
next step now is install nginx nginx is
the web server
out to the world so when we get the
request to
engine x we use that as a proxies to
reach g
unicorn and we need nginx to handle the
media files for django
so install nginx that have all
so already installed nginx we did that
in the beginning
so we just need to create a new config
file so e2c
and genex sites available
and then vi check api
jackets dot code
with with stein.com
which is the address for the web server
i'm running on now
so first we create the upstream app so
this will connect to the g
unicorn socket file which is created by
the g unicorn script
and then we want to listen to port 80
and if you come from port 80 which is
http we want to redirect you to https
and then we want to listen to 443 which
is what
https is at the back max body size
and access log error log and ssl
certificate
and i search the certificate key i will
fix
it after this is done and then set some
protocols and just make sure that ssl
is working here is the hosting for the
static files
and here is the whole thing for the
media files which is the uploaded files
and similar
and and we use the proxy to forward you
to the jackets app server which is the
socket file we created
so now everything there should be okay
i'll also add this
file in the github repository
i need to activate this now see the
sites enabled
s create a symbol like link back to that
file we created
check it no api
there now we have it here
and we can restart nginx so service
and gen x restart okay there is an error
okay it can't load the certificate so
that's the problem here
so the problem is that they can't load
the certificates
so we need to obtain them search bot
dash
ng next hd and indeed the domain name
okay maybe if i just skip using nginx
cannot load okay i just need to remove
this for now
so now i get it enter email address
called stein gmat.com
agree yes okay so then we got
that sorry um yes redirect
and then i can obtain this where we will
host the
view part of this project
and then redirect
okay so now we have the ssl certificate
and we can try to create
the symbolic link again restart nginx
okay there's a new error
okay i restarted the server and now
everything seems to be okay so if i go
to api check it
dot code with stein.com
get a bad gateway so i need to check the
log server
log files web apps check it
snow environment
okay there logs
ch own
super
okay so our problems is to be with the g
unicorn
so i need to find out what that is
failing
this couldn't create this one okay
permission denied
so then i need to go to this folder
and it seems that root is owning this
folder
so i need to change the permissions
restart
and also i want to restart supervisor
supervisor ctl restart
jackets hit enter
okay what's the status
check it's django
refresh great so now it's working i just
need to add this
to the list of allowed hosts
via django settings prod
so i need to find it first of all i can
add
http s
i can add this here because this is the
one i'm going to use
for the front end
and here i need to add it to this list
as well
restart jackets django
refresh found perfect
but it seems that it's working so i can
just try to log in to create a product
sorry i need to create a super user
so source
slash environment bin activate
python mentioned by manage product by
create super user
of course headers jungles
always something you forget to add
just want to edit here
and to the list here as well so i need
to have
two of this
like that now we need to restart again
then we can try to create the super user
admin admin jackets.com
and the password
and then we can go here login with the
user i just
created great
create categories winter winter
and summer summer
and i can create a product as well
in the winter warm
jacket warm check it
the description 199
select the picture
save so now we have products there
and if i now try to go to
api v1 products
latest products then i get it there
perfect okay i need to change this as
well
sorry that's the last thing we need to
do in the back end
yeah project models.pi
it shouldn't be this address of course
it should be this
maybe even without the lost slash there
restart refresh
and then we have them here perfect
okay so i just need to check if the
files were applied
uploaded media
uploads
okay the picture isn't there
okay we'll come back to that very soon
just want to
make sure that we have uploaded engineer
view as well so everything is working
except images
so then i first want to go in here and
go to
main.js and change this url
to api jackets
dot code with style.com
and save so now that would be the
address
and then we want to compile
all the view code so we can upload it to
the server as well
to do that we say npm run build
and understand we have a new folder here
called this this is all of the compiled
code
in like html and javascript and similar
and we need to upload this to the web
server just want to zip it first
zip dash or dist dot zip
and dist so then we can
send it to the server so sap
dist dot sip and then the address
sorry root at like that
and then my password
and now that's there so then i can go up
one folder
and say cp root dist
there unzip dist
so now i have it here but i want to
create a new folder
okay there check it
view and move this folder inside there
oops that's wrong and the
jackets underscore into jackets
view and call it dist
and if i go in here now unless lord you
will see that
root is owning this and i need to fix
that
great so now the next step is to create
a new config for view
now for nginx so cd e2c
engine x sites available
touch jackets
dot code with stein.com
the i jackets and paste them so we do
the same thing here we listen to 80 and
redirect you to https
and then we do the same here with
setting up jackets.com at
least in 443 set the ssl
it's at the correct part to these which
we have also already obtained
and we set the root folder to web apps
slash should be jackets here sorry
check it check its view dist
and the same down here jackets
so save and close i'm going to sites
enabled and lms
dot slash sites available
jackets there there
and restart
oops i was not supposed to
service
and gen x restart sorry i start to get a
little bit tired now so
sorry for all the mistakes
so if i now try to go to this address
yes everything is working there we got
the product from the live server
but the image isn't working sorry other
wrong parts for the
media files
so it's supposed to be like this media
and i need a space at the beginning
save close restart
and now the image is there and hopefully
if i refresh
the image is there as well so now
everything is working as it should
so i can go to the to-do list
and everything can be set to done here
now
now i have a working e-commerce website
built at django
and view so this is a really cool
project
you can use in your portfolio similar
just remember to change the styling
and just change a little bit more
functionality and similar
the code might not be ready for
production and you need to
change the stripe api keys for
production as similar
but i hope you have learned a lot
anyways
if you have any questions feel free to
leave me a comment below and answer as
soon as i can